welcome back to the David Pakman show.
It's great to welcome to the program today,
cal Newport, who is a computer science professor
at Georgetown Town University.
Also author of several books including most
recently digital minimalism, choosing a focus
life in a noisy world previously deep work,
which I recently recommended to my audience
a cal.
It's so great to have you on.
I appreciate it.
No, thanks for having me.
It's my pleasure.
So I've been following with great interest,
the sort of societal and cultural impact of
uh, modern media, social media technology
that includes smartphones and Netflix and
all sorts of a, a sort of on demand entertainment.
And you've also been writing extensively about
this for a long time.
Uh, I don't think it'll come as a shock to
my audience that I agree with a lot of your
conclusions, many of which we'll talk about
momentarily, but when did you first sort of
get tipped off to the idea that there is something
going on here that is impacting how people
sort of go about their days and get work done
or don't get work done or relate to other
people in the world?
Like how early on did you pick up on this
issue?
Well back in 2012 I had published a career
advice book called so good they can't ignore
you.
And one of the ideas in that book is that
getting really good at rare and valuable skills
was a huge piece of leverage and craft and
a career that was really meaningful.
So after that book came out, my readers were
asking me, okay, well how do I do that?
How do I become really good at things that
are rare and valuable?
And then I started looking into that question.
I started coming up with this tension.
I would find something that important, such
as concentration, learning, new skills, producing
at a high level.
And every time I come, couple of something
important, I would find this technological
foil that was unintentionally making it harder
to do that.
And so my 2016 book deep work was really about
this tension between how concentrating is
becoming more important in our economy.
At the same time that technology in the workplace
was making us worse a concentrating.
And so that book came out and then my readers
pushed back again and said, yeah, but what
about life outside of work?
We're feeling like technology, especially
what's happening on our smartphones is taking
us away or reducing the quality of what we're
trying to do with our life outside of the
professional context.
So again, that pushed me into that for digital
minimalism.
And so this has been the story of my writing
life, let's say over the last seven years
or so, is keep coming up against these tensions
between human striving to flourish and unintentional
consequences of technology that are holding
them back from it.
So let's focus in a little bit first on the
deep work component and then in part two we'll
dig in more deeply into what you outlined
in in digital minimalism.
I thought before I read your books that I
was handling a lot of these issues really
pretty well.
I, I was sort of like satisfied with what
I felt was my work life balance, my relationship
to technology, the amount of time I was spending
on sort of what, what I would consider to
be like the core important tasks of for what
I do, which are researching the stories that
make it onto onto my show, preparing and actually
filming the show.
And when I read deep work, I realized a huge
percentage of what I'm doing is this so called
shallow work, which is everything from responding
to emails, dealing with administrative tasks,
uh, and, and sort of all of those things that
aren't really the core of what it is that
I'm doing for people who, who are not aware
of, of what you're arguing, what percentage
of of many jobs now is consumed, not by sort
of like the core deep work.
But by this shallow work that you identify
as not not sort of core to what one is trying
to achieve to produce value.
I think for many knowledge work positions
these days accidentally we've gotten to a
place where the vast majority of people's
time is being spent, uh, either on non deep
activities or being done somehow roughly in
parallel with the activities greatly reducing
their efficacy.
In other words, I think we're doing a really
poor job right now, allocating cognitive resources
and an elite knowledge economy like we have
in the US.
The number one capital resource is attention
capital, the ability of human brains, human
brains that you employ to actually concentrate
and produce information with new value.
And we're doing a terrible job right now at
getting the best return on that capital investment.
And so even just having this terminology,
there's a difference between deep work where
you're trying to actually extract maximum
value from the brain versus shallow work,
which is how you keep the lights on in the
trains run on time.
Just understand that there's a difference
between those two, allows you to have these
types of realizations that wait a second,
we're paying all this money to house all of
these brains and the put them in Nice offices
and air conditioning and heat them and give
them benefits so that the brains can be healthy
and produce value.
And yet we're then allowing these brains to
spend the vast majority of their time doing
sort of non high level non-skilled sort of
administrative style work.
Yeah, I mean it's, I, I'm realizing that,
you know, a lot of this time you're, you're
doing all of that stuff to sit around and
effectively answer emails and be a go between,
between other other individuals.
So at the very top level, obviously we can't,
uh, go, go through everything in an interview
like this.
But one of the things you talk about is very
clearly delineating when it is that you were
doing that shallow work and a lot of professions,
you can't get rid of it altogether.
But it seems that condensing it and compartmentalizing
it into particularly planned and scheduled
times is is sort of one idea that can be effective
for a lot of people.
From a very practical standpoint, is that
doable for people in most professions?
I feel like that's one of the most common
things people say when I tell them I'm trying
to do this.
They say sounds great if you can do it, but
here's why it would not apply to my particular
profession, which I'm guessing you hear often.
I hear it a lot and there's certainly our
professions in which let's say concentrated
cognitive work, what I call deep work is not
that important, but I also think that people
vastly overestimate the number of professions
for which that's actually true and what I
recommend is that people should have clarity.
This is how much deep work I'm doing.
This is how much non deep or shallow work
I'm doing and they should have some sense
of for my position, what is the optimal ratio
in a normal week?
What is the optimal ratio of deep work hours
to shallow work hours from the perspective
of what optimizes the value I produced for
the organization, I think people should have
an answer to this question.
I think people should be discussing this question
with their supervisors or bosses if they work
for someone else.
I think people should be measuring and seeing
how well they're coming up against this ratio.
Now the ratio is going to be different for
different people.
It can be different for different jobs.
Some jobs, let's say you're a novelist, probably
the ratio should be almost a hundred percent
deep work at another job.
Let's say you're a lobbyist here in DC where
I am, well maybe almost all of what you're
doing is just connecting to people and there's
very little deep work, but you should have
an answer.
We can't blind ourselves to how much deep
work we're doing versus how much shall on
what would be better and the feedback I'm
getting from my readers is that once you get
quantitative on this, this is the ratio that
makes sense for my job.
Here's where I am.
There's a gap.
Once your once your quantitative on this you
see the stark numbers.
This sparks a lot more cultural changes than
people assume is possible.
Now a lot of this also depends for people
who are not in a sort of supervisor business
owner or entrepreneur role role but rather
are working for somebody else.
A big part of this is is as you mentioned,
having these conversations with whoever is
kind of monitoring your time because the expectations
from a sort of modern employers often would
create a problem for a lot of people.
If they were saying, hey, you know half the
day I'm going to try to do three hours for
example, or four hours, which you've suggested,
if I recall correctly, maybe sort of the Max
for this deep work that someone may be able
to get done in a normal day.
A lot of this has to do with the culture in
which people are working, does it not?
It does, but we think that these cultures
are entrenched and are immutable, but the
reality is often that they're arbitrary and
emergent and are much more malleable than
we think once we actually come at them.
Precisely.
So here's a classic story that I heard after
my book came out.
I was someone who was in marketing for Silicon
Valley firms.
So he wrote white papers, which are incredibly
complex and really from deep work.
And so he went to his CEO and said, okay,
here's what deep work is.
Here's what shallow work is.
What ratio of deep to shallow work makes the
most sense for my job.
Now, he clarified before he did this, he was
very nervous because this organization had
a slack culture in which if you did not respond
to slack right away, you were seen as ironically
slacking off.
But he had this conversation with the CEO
and he said it became, uh, almost immediately
clear that it would be crazy for the answer
to be zero.
They decided that 50, 50 made sense and it
took about a week for them to change this.
She just told his team these two hours in
the morning, these two hours in the afternoon,
that's when he is doing his deep work.
He's not to be interrupted, don't expect to
response.
It took people about a week to get used to
it and now suddenly this guy has a 50 50 deep
shallow ratio with complete buy in from his
team and the CEO and it took them only at
let's say a week to actually change where
before he had this conversation, he was convinced
this is a slack place.
This is a slack office.
If you're not responding, it'll never work.
So I think we think these cultures are there
for a reason and they're entrenched and our
bosses are going to insist on them.
You push a little deeper and you realize often
nobody is happy with them and a great change
is possible as long as you're clear, positive
and quantitative about why you're making the
change.
Yeah.
After reading deep work and a bunch of articles
about slack, I immediately canceled slack
fully and told all of my employees were, were
simply not using it.
And in fact, I went further.
I said, hey, you know, I, I'm really going
to be trying to, to spend most of the morning,
uh, on, on what is I think is the most important
thing, which is really researching and preparing
for the show.
So I will check my email when I get to my
desk and I will not look at email again for
several hours.
If there's a real emergency text me, I'm not
going to ignore you.
Right?
I mean, these are employees and to some degree
I need to be available.
But if it's not an emergency, you're not going
to hear back from me.
And very quickly everybody just does seem
to adjust.
So a lot of it is, as you're saying, what
you think is necessary versus what, what is
sort of actually a necessary in many cases.
And, and along those same lines, I'm curious,
um, is there a way or do you have any anecdotes
about how we can quantify the effect of these
longer periods of concentration on productivity?
Because I think one of the biggest misconceptions
is that one gets more done by switching between
tasks and sort of covering a lot of basis
in a less, in a less deep way, but qualitatively
and quantitatively, it actually seems counter,
uh, uh, to, to, to the reality.
How can we sort of explain how the focus for
longer periods of time quantitatively actually
allows people to get more done?
Well, I think a mindset shift that helps here
is thinking about efforts in terms of uh,
let's say learn skilled applied.
So if you're, if you're answering emails or,
or, or jumping on calls or moving things back
and forth in PowerPoint, these are all activities
that don't actually require the application
of sort of hard one or elite level.
And so the value they're producing is not
actually that high as compared to, let's say
you're thinking very deeply on researching
a piece you're going to do for your show is
something that you're uniquely qualified to
do.
That builds on a large foundation of experience.
It requires a lot of concentration that is
going to produce much more value because that's
much more rare or hard to do.
And so I have this trick in the book where
I talk about quantify the activity you're
about to do with how many hours would it take
to train a smart recent college Grad to do
what you're about to do.
And if the answer is I could probably train
them in a few hours to do this, then that's
probably not an activity that's going to be
massively value producing.
But if on the other hand it's, well, it probably
would take them four or five years of training
and work experience where they could even
approximate what I'm about to be doing.
You're getting a much higher return on the
cognitive resource for that activity.
And so I think this mindset shift is crucial.
Shallow work is necessary, uh, to keep things
running, but it doesn't produce a ton of value.
Deep work is the actual, you know, the wrench
is on the car building the thing that's going
to go off the assembly line to be sold type
activities.
Once you have that mindset shift, you begin
to worry about shallow work and how much time
your employees are spending on it and really
start to focus on on the deep work because
that's what produces the value.
So in part two we'll dig in much more deeply
to digital minimalism, which is the latest
book, but to start getting us in that mindset
of and transitioning into that, can you talk
a little bit about what sort of psychological
problems or emotional, uh, sort of sort of
issues can arise when we become attached to
this type of quote multitasking, which I know
we, we, you and I actually take issue with
the idea that it's actually multitasking rather
than switching between things really quickly.
What are the issues that can develop longer
term in terms of concentration, in terms of
emotional issues as well?
Well, there's a few issues.
One is context switching.
So switching to an inbox and then back to
a primary task reduces your cognitive capacity
and that effect takes awhile to clear out.
And so if you are constantly having to jump
over and check an inbox or a slack channel,
then returned to what you're doing.
You're not really single tasking.
This context switching is having a huge psychological
burden on, on what you're actually able to
produce.
And so it's like buying a fancy piece of equipment
in the, in a factory, but then allowing sand
to build up in his gear so it can't function
as hard.
It's a real crisis.
I don't think we understand it.
There's also a social drag on a workplace
that's built on constant ongoing conversation.
Our brains are sophisticated social computers
that evolved in a context where we didn't
have digital inboxes, and so you might know
rationally that those 600 unread emails in
your inbox are different than let's say a
member of your tribe sitting across from the
fire trying to get your attention.
But there's a deep part of your brain that
doesn't see that distinction and it sees it
as social obligations that you are ignoring,
which is according to your brain, a crisis.
And so that makes us anxious and uneasy about
all this.
The, the communication that we're, we're not
answering to makes us check things more compulsively.
And then finally, we have a long term ability
on our ability, a degregation our ability
to concentrate.
If your brain gets used to constantly switching
between different stimuli, when it comes time
to really lock in and use those neurons to
produce information that's valuable for you
and your organization, you're going to be
worse at it.
Just like if you're a professional athlete
and you're smoking outside of, uh, outside
of the games and you're training, it's going
to have an effect on the field.
Same thing if your whole life is constantly
moving back and forth between professional
and personal inboxes and screens and Apps,
your brain is going to get worse and worse.
It actually locking in and producing new and
valuable information.
That's actually a great place to pause our
conversation with cal Newport.
We've been talking about a two of his books,
digital minimalism, as well as the
fork, which is now, uh, three years old.
We will continue the conversation with them
on tomorrow's program and dig further into
digital minimalism.
The latest
book